en
1997 la compagnie us robotics lancer un
petit gadget qui va se vendre à un
million d'exemplaires ça s'appelle le
pommeau parle est un petit assistant
personnel qui a connu des beaux jours
avant de tomber en désuétude quand sont
arrivés les téléphones multifonctions il
est aujourd'hui enterrée ou à peu près
ce qui lui vaut une présence aussi
matière de gadgets dont le directeur
général est avec nous monsieur le
directeur vous avez eu un pas entre vous
oui moi j'en ai eu trois plutôt qu'un
j'ai eu un en sprint j'ai eu un impact à
71 j'ai eu un thé xx vous ce que vous en
ai eu 209 et du 2 au 6 mai donc il est
assez répandue on nous en sommes
l'épreuve vivant on peut penser que ça
allait ça allait faire ce que le
téléphone est déjà fait aujourd'hui oui
ça faisait pour nom mais on n'avait pas
accès internet avec ces dispositifs là
on installer des applications je peux si
vous vous rappelez il y avait le livre
la cia y est avec toutes les données sur
tous les pays tout le monde installé ça
il y avait des conjugueur délivre aussi
en format électronique
d'autres formats dont on entend peu près
plus parler comme ça ici l'eau des
programmes pour retravailler des textes
qui étaient dans word documentstogo
chaque jour
c'était ce qu'on avait de mieux j'ai
parlé avec une fan du pin de nos
collègues jeunesse à la recherche
monique lapointe elle avait encore le
sait il y a quelques mois on écoute le
moyen j'ai eu mon premier enfant enduit
mines selon rmc ça même si on nettoie le
truc pour recharger on appelait prendre
dans cette boîte le je pense que nos 400
jetons capable d'ouvrir ses traits bout
la voix
et pillon s'ils écoutent ça tu vas rire
il ya aussi tout un sac de morceaux pour
réparer par exemple quand l'écran lâcher
quand les piles lâchait quand les
touches lâché fait y avait ça donc pour
s'éteindre merveille quand je vois dans
les années 90 1 90 et même début 2006 et
est immensément pratique c'est comme moi
dans mon métier je suis recherchiste
donc j'ai des milliers de numéros de
téléphone quand tu avais sur sur des
carrés des ça marchait poste un paquet
de trouble et puis en plus savez
beaucoup de fonctions tu peux faire des
catégories c'était très utiles pour le
travail et il fallait aussi écrire d'une
façon particulière sur le banc parce
qu'il ne reconnaissait pas l'écriture
naturel oui mais ça ça venait assez vite
que tu t'habitues et à faire des liens
c'était vraiment point de problème
est-ce que l'habitude que vous avez
prises décrire d'une certaine façon on
survole pendent en quelque sorte parce
que ça et transversale sur votre façon
d'écrire au quotidien' avec un crayon la
façon de faire lit et relit eux et c'est
une excellente question écoute je sais
pas c'est très possible sauf qu'on
équipe presque plus jamais à l'année
miss que j'adorais aussi cet effet
qu'ils pouvaient be mais si tu veux
transmettre des informations à l'autre
personne qui devant toi là c'était
vraiment ce j'adorerais ça donc via
infrarouge oui exactement
j'ai un collègue avec qui on se faisait
un plaisir de son passé notre temps
c'était c'était hyper pratique en même
temps c'est un petit côté jeu soyons
honnêtes le guilly cosy c'était vraiment
non c'était chouette ça valait vraiment
vraiment la peine le moment donné tout
le monde capoté parce que j'avais un
pente puis après ça mon capoté parce que
j'étais anti diluviennes parce que
j'avais encore informent le vus pendant
combien 12 13 ans j'ai changé parce que
j'ai transféré sur mon ipod touch
j'avoue que je peux plus malheureuse
maintenant est ce qu'il ya des choses
qui vous manquent de ce petit assistant
personnel que vous retrouvez pas par
exemple avec votre ipod je pense que
peut-être les catégories qui sont pas
nécessairement adaptée aux gens de
travail qu'on fait mais à part ça c'est
assez semblable comme mais le temps que
vous l'avez vu ça a été vraiment utile
par exemple si je vous comprends bien
utile immensément utile immensément
utile c'était très rapide en plus mon
nom c'était vraiment je regrette rien
puis un jour les ipod puis l'iphone
tomberait tous en panne puis on
retournera aux pommes
ce serait correct jusque là c'était plus
dit il y en avait plus nouveau palm
risquer de tout perdre merci beaucoup
unique y'a pas de quoi
mais c'est vrai qu'on pourra encore
s'arranger avec un parent tu pour les
fonctions de base le problème c'est que
maintenant qu'on a connu le petit gadget
ou mais aussi un téléphone
pas d'internet mobile et le poids de
nuages informatiques tout en le disait
devait être sur les appareils
maintenance et décentralisé et c'est
tout devient possible via les
applications et internet aux suis et je
vous montre quelque chose que vous allez
tu étais mais c'est un pas envoyer 3c
qui est encore même s'il a pas été
chargée depuis un an voilà c'est
fonctionne encore alors faut pas
l'envoyer au cimetière n'est pas mon
merci beaucoup je n'ai croisé un prix
d'au revoir